en gros cadre flou et avancent le plus
comme si tu es bon voilà suspendu
possible pour une très lente avancée
cherche pas faire barrer spécialement
dernière répétition pour des dalles au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce
thriller à l'univers sombre et sorti
tout droit de l'imagination de marion
pellissier
comme son nom l'indiqué ce huis clos
mentale revisite un mythe antique moi
j'aime bien travailler
avec des univers étrange
inquiétant mais qui propose une
métaphore possible une lecture une autre
lecture possible que le concret à qui
propose donc là c'est c'est que des
grilles des baronnies vert métallique
avec des parois de grillage qui
représente le dédale pour créer ce
spectacle de deux heures six acteurs une
équipe technique participent à cette
création sur deux semaines ensemble ils
ont imaginé ce labyrinthe souvent tu
peux rester à le regarder en en même les
la moitié de la beauté partir du jusqu'à
maintenant que dire de barrez lui donc
je suis entendu j'ai l'intention de
rester
moi même je peux
avoir j'ai pas toujours je n'ai pas
toujours les mots sur les choses et
j'aime bien être déplacé dans dans ce
que je projette donc je quand j'ai une
idée claire mais j'aime bien que cette
idée claire elle évolue avec l'équipe
avec laquelle je travaille en tant que
comédien le le plaisir qu'on éprouve
déjà c'est de la recherche recherche
autour de la matière textuelle du sujet
des différentes figures que chacun des
comédiens comédiennes des spectacles
interprète est donc temps de développer
une atmosphère atypique à découvrir le
mardi 9 et mercredi 10 novembre à 20h30
sur la scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec un seul
mot d'ordre laisser libre cours à son
imagination